SEAN HANNITY STANDING BY IN
NEW YORK, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> Sean: THINK YOU ON THIS
MONDAY.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE ARE TRACKING MULTIPLE MAJOR
STORIES THAT WILL IMPACT YOUR
LIFE INCLUDING THE SHOCKING THE
SCENE FROM NEW YORK CITY, LOOK
AT THIS FRIDAY NIGHT 11:30 A.M.
BROAD DAYLIGHT, THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK CITY, THAT MAN RIGHT
THERE AND BEATEN, SLASHED,
ROBBED BY A GROUP OF 12 PEOPLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, VIOLENT CRIME
IS NOW SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL
IN MANY OF AMERICA’S MAJOR
CITIES.
IT GOES BACK TO RIOTING IN
PORTLAND, SEATTLE, AND DENVER
THIS WEEK.
THIS IS WHAT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE AND HELPING PEOPLE
ARRESTED GET FREE BAIL
KAMALA HARRIS AND NOT SPEAKING
OUT AND CALLING RIOTS RIOTS LIKE
LAST SUMMER.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
IF MORE SCARY TIMES.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE TONIGHT.
ALSO, NANCY PELOSI’S PRAYERFUL
AND SOLEMN DUTY, RADICAL
EXTREMISTS TO SMEAR THE
PRESIDENT EVEN OUT OF OFFICE FOR
ALL ETERNITY IS NOW OFFICIALLY
REACHING THE SENATE.
COMING UP, WE WILL HAVE THE VERY
LATEST DETAILS FROM THE
DEMOCRATS UNCONSTITUTIONAL POST
PRESIDENTIAL IMPEACHMENT CHARADE
WHICH IS FALLING APART.
IT IS NOW OFFICIALLY BLOWING UP
IN THE FACES OF BIDEN AND EVERY
OTHER DEMOCRAT IN THE SWAMP.
SENATORS BY THE WAY, REPUBLICANS
ARE NOW FORCEFULLY SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
AS OF TODAY, IT’S A FOREGONE
INCLUDE WOW CONCLUSION IT WILL
BE IN ACQUITTAL AND THEY KNOW
THEY’RE DEAD ON ARRIVAL.
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
RIGHTLY NOW REFUSING TO PRESIDE
OVER THE TRIAL, THE LATEST SHOW
AND OF COURSE HAVE BIDEN REALLY
CARED ABOUT UNITY, HE COULD PUT
A STOP TO IT NOW, SO MUCH FOR
THAT UNITY BE YES, WORDS, NO
MEETING, SMOKE AND MIRRORS.
OBVIOUSLY DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
UNITY AT ALL WHATSOEVER, HE’S
OUT OF OFFICE.
ARE YOU HAPPY?
IT READS LIKE A WISH LIST FOR
THE RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST
BASE.
OR THEY THE ONES IN CHARGE AND
BIDEN IS NOW HALTING ALL
BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION.
STOPPING ALL DEPORTATIONS,
AMNESTY IS ON THE WAY,
INCORPORATING LEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TO THE U.S. CENSUS AND WAGING
WAR ON AMERICAN OIL AND GAS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE NOW BEING
LAID OFF BECAUSE OF BIDEN’S
CANCELLATION OF THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE, THE BIDEN-OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
FOUR YEARS AGO, THEY PREDICTED
2 BILLION IN WAGES, IF THE
PIPELINE WAS EVER BUILT BUT THEY
NEVER LIFTED A FINGER,
DONALD TRUMP GOT THAT DONE AND
NOW BIDEN’S RADICAL AGENDA IS
LITERALLY TAKING THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN JOBS, HURTING AMERICAN
FAMILIES ALL WHILE ECONOMIC
STRESS IS THE NORM FOR WAY TOO
MANY OF OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
BECAUSE OF COVID AND OF COURSE
THE SUBSEQUENT LOCKDOWNS.
WE WILL HEAR FROM ONE OF THOSE
WORKERS, A FELLOW AMERICAN IN
JUST A MOMENT.
WHAT’S HIS LIFE LIKE NOW AND
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN, THIS
GUY LOST HIS JOB.
SO TO JOE’S FAWNING FANS AND BIG
TECH, THE MEDIA MOB, THIS IS WHY
I’M CRITICAL NOW.
THIS EARLY OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THIS IS WHY I
RIGHTLY CALLED HIS FIRST WEEK IN
OFFICE HAVE PENDING DISASTER.
THE MOB SAYING HANNITY’S ALREADY
SAYING JOE IS FAILING.
WELL, THESE POLICIES WILL ALWAYS
FAIL.
WHY?
CHAPTER FOUR OF MY BOOK ACTUALLY
HAS A WHOLE CHAPTER IN THERE
THAT SAYS SOCIALISM AND ITS
HISTORY OF FAILURE.
IT WILL FAIL AGAIN.
THIS IS WHY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
VET JOE BIDEN AND ALL HIS
POLICIES 99% SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS IN THIS COUNTRY ON
NOW WHAT WE WILL CALL A
SYCOPHANTIC VACATION, SO PER
USUAL, WE END UP DOING THOSE
JOBS AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST CANCEL
CULTURE.
IT IS NOW WORSE THAN EVER.
A MORE OPPRESSIVE THAN EVER,
MORE CHILLING THAN EVER, IN
EMBRACE OF AUTHORITARIANISM AND
SOME ON THE LEFT ARE CALLING ON
THE GOVERNMENT TO CENSOR,
REGULATE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IN OTHER WORDS, SPEECH THEY
DON’T LIKE OR AGREE WITH.
AND SOME EVEN ON SO-CALLED NEWS
NETWORKS WANT FOX NEWS RIPPED
OFF THE AIR WAY.
THEY WANT THIS SHOW CANCELED.
TALK ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE.
IF THEY HAVE THE BIGGEST
PROPAGANDA, THE BIGGEST
PURVEYORS OF LIES, HATRED IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND I HAVE FIVE YEARS WORTH OF
NEVER-ENDING MATERIAL.
OTHERS HAVE CONTINUOUSLY AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY PRAISED BIG
TECH CENSORSHIP OF CONSERVATIVES
AND OF COURSE THE CENSORSHIP OF
REAL STORIES IN THE LEAD UP TO
THE ELECTION.
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY HAD A BOOK
DEAL CANCELED.
THEY WANT TO USE THE 14TH
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE HIM AND
TED CRUZ FOR DARING TO ASK FOR
AN AUDIT OF ELECTION.
SORRY IF YOU DISAGREE, BUT
THAT’S WHAT THIS COUNTRY WAS
BUILT ON ALL BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORTED A TEN DAY AUDIT OF OUR
ELECTION RESULTS, SOMETHING
DEMOCRATS IN THE PAST HAVE DONE.
ENCOURAGED ALL AMERICANS TO TAKE
A STAND AGAINST THE MUZZLING OF
AMERICA.
WHEN CANDIDATE BIDEN THEN USE
THE PANDEMIC TO BASH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN ONE OF HIS
RARE APPEARANCES.
IN FACT, HE PERSONALLY BLAME THE
PRESIDENT PRETTY MUCH FOR EVERY
COVID DEATH, NOT CHINA, NO,
THERE’S ONLY ONE PERSON ON THIS
EARTH TO BLAME, DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT HAD DONE
HIS JOB FROM THE BEGINNING, ALL
THE PEOPLE WOULD STILL BE ALIVE,
ALL THE PEOPLE -- I’M NOT MAKING
THIS UP, JUST LOOK AT THE DATA.
LOOK AT THE DATA.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE DATA,
OKAY.
THEY CLAIMED THEY HAD A PLAN TO
BE COVID-19, THEY VOWED TO GET
THE VIRUS UNDER CONTROL,
DELIVERY OF IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
WORKING FAMILIES AND APPARENTLY
THAT’S NOT THE CASE, LOOK AT
THIS, NOW THERE IS NOTHING HE
CAN REALLY DO TO CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE PANDEMIC,
THAT’S NOT WHAT HE WAS SAYING IN
THE CAMPAIGN AT ALL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF WE FAIL TO ACT, THERE WILL
BE A WAVE OF THE EVICTIONS AND
FORECLOSURES IN THE COMING
MONTHS AS THIS PANDEMIC RAGES ON
BECAUSE THERE’S NOTHING WE CAN
DO TO CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF
THE PANDEMIC IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS.
>> Sean: KEEP IN MIND MULTIPLE
VACCINES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DEPLOYED THANKS TO DONALD TRUMP
AND BY THE WAY, AROUND 1 MILLION
DOSES ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED AND
PUT IN PEOPLE’S ARMS EVERY
SINGLE DAY JUST LIKE DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
REMEMBER THOSE INTERNATIONAL
TRAVEL BANDS PRESIDENT TRUMP
IMPLEMENTED?
ACTUALLY IN ABOUT SIX DAYS
EXACTLY ONE YEAR AGO TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19, NOW THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THEMSELVES
ARE EXTENDING THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS, BUT YOU REMEMBER
AFTER THE PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED
THAT ABOUT A YEAR AGO ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, JOE OUT THERE
TWEETING THAT THE TRAVEL BAN WAS
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIC, AND
FEARMONGERING AND THEN IN MARCH,
BIDEN AGAIN CALLED THE COVID-19
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS XENOPHOBIC,
FEARMONGERING.
I GUESS THAT MAKES JOE BIDEN
XENOPHOBIC AND A FEARMONGERING
OR PERIOD OF OUR OWN PETER DOOCY
ASKED BIDEN’S PRESS SECRETARY
ABOUT THIS AND AS PER USUAL, THE
ANSWER WAS MISLEADING.
>> WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
IMPOSING TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS AND
MARCHED SPECIFICALLY ON CHINA,
THEN CANDIDATE BIDEN CALLED IT
XENOPHOBIC AND FEARMONGERING, SO
NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS PUTTING
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ON PEOPLE
COMING IN FROM OTHER COUNTRY.
>> EVEN BEFORE HE WAS
INAUGURATED, TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SAFE.
>> Sean: THAT YOU THINK WE ARE
THAT STUPID OR JUST NOT AWARE
THAT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
COVID-19 TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS?
ONE THING HAS BECOME VERY CLEAR
AND THAT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT PLAN TO
HOLD CHINA RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYTHING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CHINA’S ENGAGED IN CONDUCT
THAT HURTS AMERICAN WORKERS AND
THREATENS OUR ALLIANCES AND
INFLUENCES IN INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
CHINA IS GROWING MORE
AUTHORITARIAN AT HOME AND MORE
ASSERTIVE ABROAD AND CHINA IS
NOW THREATENING OUR VALUES IN
SIGNIFICANT WAYS THAT IT REQUIRE
A NEW U.S. APPROACH AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE REASONS AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THAT WE WANT TO APPROACH
THIS WITH STRATEGIC PATIENCE.
>> Sean: THEY’RE HAPPY WE’RE
GOING TO GET OUT OF THE OIL AND
ENERGY BUSINESS BECAUSE THEY
WILL MAKE A LOT OF MONEY TOO.
NOT THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE,
CLEARLY A FRIENDLY RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE MALIGNANT REGIME,
HOSTILE REGIME THAT AFFECTED THE
WORLD WITH COVID-19 IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO BIDEN.
JOE’S SON MADE ALL THAT MONEY.
THE THOUSANDS OF WORKERS BY THE
WAY THAT ACTUALLY RELIED ON HIGH
PAYING CAREER JOBS IN THE ENERGY